Narrator:
This is the "Shark Tank"
Where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-Lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
We did $1.125 million
in sales.
Herjavec: Whoa!
O'Leary: Wow!
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
The idea of it
is so wrong, I'm out.
Let me -- Let me just stop you
right there.
You can't stop him
if he's out.
Narrator: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
this tastes great.
...they're ready to invest
using their own money.
I was going to ignore you
completely,
but now I'm Loving you.
That's a first. He tried
to steal Someone's employee.
Narrator: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
What I can do for you
is take you to retail.
Well, I'll make it
even more interesting.
What do you say?
Can I ask you
a few more questions?
Don't mistake my kindness
for weakness.
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went from
waiting tables in manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-Estate empire.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of qvc,
holds over 100 patents,
and has launched
over 300 products
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And mark cuban -- Notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the Nba's Dallas mavericks.
First into the tank is a couple
from san Ramon, california,
with a better solution
to a school-Day dilemma.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Cyndi.
And I'm Paul.
And we're here today seeking
$150,000 investment
in exchange for 15%
of our lunch-Box company, yubo.
[ bell rings ]
lunchtime!
Lunchtime!
It all started
four years ago.
As the proud parents
of two beautiful, little girls,
we'd send them to school
with your typical
fabric lunch box
filled with
Those plastic baggies
and "Personalized" With a
permanent Marker on the outside.
We were going through nearly
2,000 plastic baggies a year,
not to mention
these lunch boxes
would come home
completely nasty.
They were
not dishwasher-Safe,
so I would do my best
to wipe it down.
And, oh,
it was clean, right?
Wrong!
[ Laughs ]
We looked everywhere
for a lunch box that was easy to
clean, good for the environment,
and we couldn't find it,
so we created yubo.
Yubo is
the only lunch box
Where kids can create
their own designs
and change them out
whenever their tastes change
so you don't have to buy
a whole new lunch box.
You just pop in
a new design.
You have
a whole new look.
And if you spill yogurt
or crumbs, it's not a problem.
Just rinse it out in the sink
or throw it in the dishwasher.
Yubo comes with a set
of reusable fruit containers
and a custom-Fit ice pack
so food stays fresh.
We made you custom yubos.
All you do is --
HERJAVEC: Oh, very cool.
See if you can
recognize yourself.
Oh, oh!
[ laughs ]
they're simple to open.
Just hold on the middle
and grab on any corner.
Thank you.
Cyndi: Barbara.
Corcoran: Ah! Great.
And when you want
to close it back up,
just push on All four corners --
Super-Simple.
Cute, right?
So come on, sharks.
Let's do lunch!
[ Bell rings ]
Lunchtime's over, girls.
[ laughter ]
PAUL: So, you'll notice
there's no hinges.
There's no zippers
to break.
Super-Simple.
Open and close.
Great job.
Herjavec: Very clever.
Thank you.
Are these add-Ons,
or do these come with it?
We have two models.
We have
our basic lunch box,
which comes empty
at a lower price point.
And what's that price point?
This is -- $21.95.
And then we have
our deluxe model
that comes with
what you see there,
and that can retail
anywhere from $30
for no personalization
on it
or up to $40 when you want
to personalize it.
When you think about something
like this,
I mean, you think about how easy
this is to come apart,
that's why this type of a design
is so amazing.
You could take it apart
and put it in the dishwasher.
Exactly.
That -- That's one of the unique
selling attributes.
Absolutely.
Correct.
Paul, I think it's very clever,
'cause they get filthy.
That's what I think is
so smart about it.
Right.
They get gross.
Great presentation,
great name, great design.
Thank you.
I got to believe that
you're now at the cusp
of going to retail,
'cause you know
you got to get it there.
Absolutely, absolutely.
Absolutely.
I think most Moms Buy
lunch boxes
when they're walking down
the aisle, see it, and say,
"Need a lunch box."
Absolutely.
We have about 100 retail stores
across the nation.
We also are sold
internationally.
We have a handful
of international distributors.
Corcoran: Cyndi, what does
a typical lunch box sell for?
$15, $20.
So, how long have you been
selling? How many have you sold?
We've been on the market
for four years.
This year, we're on track
to do about
between $200,000
and $250,000.
Wow.
Greiner: do you have a patent
on this?
We do. Two patents.
We own a design patent
and a utility patent.
We own
our yubo trademark.
And our vision
for the company
not only is to expand in the
channels that we're already in,
but I have another vision.
So, Barbara,
I know you have a daughter.
Let's think back
to when she was Younger
and you took her
to the happiest place on earth
for the first time,
to the amusement park
we all know.
She's filled
with excitement.
She meets her favorite Princess
for the very first time,
and somebody photographs
that moment.
Imagine that photograph
is waiting for her
on her lunch box
in that gift shop.
Mm.
Do you have that deal
in place?
That's why we're here.
We do not.
We do not have that deal
in place.
So...
we would love to have that deal
in place.
Did you design this yourself?
He and I came up with the idea
together.
So, how much money
did you have to put out?
We have invested in Total about
$350,000 of our own money.
With our industrial designer,
we didn't have the cash
to pay what he would naturally
charge up front.
We had no sales.
We had no product.
Greiner:
You gave him a piece.
We gave him a piece.
Absolutely.
Cuban: That's okay.
That's okay.
How much did you give him?
He owns 20% of our company.
We own 80%.
And he has a royalty,
to be clear.
Oh.
How much is the royalty?
He has a 5% to 1%.
It's a sliding scale
based on the units sold.
I think
he's Kevin's cousin.
Ah.
Yes.
And is that in Perpetuity?
Uh, it is.
It is.
So, when -- When would it
drop down to 1%?
750,000 units.
But it's 5% of the cost
of the unit.
It's 5% of sales.
Oh.
Net sales.
Mm-hmm.
Wow.
That's steep. Ooh.
We wouldn't be here today
if we didn't do that,
so we're very satisfied
with that deal.
Cuban:
Guys, guys, I got to tell you,
this is such
a competitive industry.
Mm-hmm.
I mean,
you said you invested 350k.
Mm-hmm.
And your sales are nowhere
near that.
Mm-hmm.
The idea
of a perpetual royalty
I think is so wrong,
I'm out.
Let me -- Let me just stop you
right there.
So, mark --
You can't stop him
if he's out.
Cyndi, let me tell you
what I object to on this.
This is rather large,
so I could not put this
in her backpack.
It wouldn't fit.
Okay.
And I find that to be
a problem.
Okay.
I think
it's a charming product.
I love the personalization
of it.
But it's too big.
I'm out.
Thank you, Barbara.
I understand.
Let me throw an offer at you,
because I'm -- I'm interested.
There's a fair amount of work
that has to happen here
to pull it into retail,
where 90% of the boxes
are bought,
where I bought mine
my whole life with my kids.
And I think I can help there
in a lot of ways.
I'll give you the $150,000
for 10% equity in your company.
Plus, I want the same royalty
deal that your designer has --
5% sliding down to 1%
based on sales volumes.
Paul: Unfortunately,
that type of a royalty
is probably unsustainable.
I'll give you the $150,000
for 30%.
You realize he just cut
your valuation in half?
I think we're gonna make it.
I think this is
a real home run.
This is a time to make
a decision. What do you say?
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Well, let me put a little
pressure on Robert for you.
I can -- I might be able
to squeeze him out.
May I just ask you
one question?
Herjavec: What do you say?
What do you say?
Well, I'll make it
even more interesting.
Narrator:
Two sharks are out.
Paul and Cyndi
have two offers --
One from Kevin,
who is offering $150,000
for a 10% stake
plus a sliding 5% to 1% royalty
based on sales.
Robert is offering $150,000
for a 30% stake.
But Lori may also want to bite.
Well, I'll make it
even more interesting.
[ laughter ]
great.
We'd love to hear it.
I'm gonna offer you
the 150k...
...for 20%.
And I'm already in Disney.
I also have a relationship
with walmart.
Herjavec: I think we can all
get you into Disney.
I believe
in the product.
Robert's at 30% equity.
Lori's at 20%.
You basically told me
you're not gonna look at my
offer with a royalty, correct?
Right.
That's fair.
All right, so,
I'll give you the $150,000.
I'm gonna set a ratchet --
I'm gonna go at 20%,
but you can buy me
all the way back down to 12.5%
if you pay me back my $150,000
in 18 months.
What if they don't?
I stay at 20%.
It's like
a roulette wheel.
I would give you
a similar deal.
Cyndi: Okay.
$150,000 for 15%.
But you have to pay me back
the 150k
within the first 15 months.
I just saved you
$265,000.
[ laughs ]
That's what happened
there.
Thank you, Mr. Wonderful.
I don't need
the money back.
I'll give you the $150,000
for 15% --
Exactly
what you asked for.
What I can do for you
is take you to retail
and help you
go through Disney.
You don't have to pay me back
in 15 months.
I'm not
a loan tank kind of guy.
[ both laugh ]
I think there's
lots of talk.
O'Leary:
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me put some more pressure
on everybody.
Paul, I gave you exactly --
Let me put
some more pressure on,
'cause I saved you
a ton of money.
I'm gonna say
one last thing.
People can throw money
at you all day long.
Paul, I gave you exactly
what you're looking for today.
Paul: Yes.
But if they don't know
what to do with it,
then it's really
not very valuable.
Well, Robert,
can I ask you?
Lori gave some examples
of already being in Disney
and having a relationship
with walmart.
Cuban: Let me -- on --
on Disney -- Let me --
Yeah, but you're not even
on this.
Not to jump on Robert.
I'm just gonna educate them.
People from Disney come in,
and they say,
"All the products that you guys
invested in 'Shark Tank' --
We'd love to find
a way to get them in Disney."
To all of us.
And they've just got to
go through a process.
But why is there only one
that's in Disney now
and "Shark Tank's" Been on
for so many years?
Because different --
Because different products
have different types --
have different test terms.
No, it's because
you have to know
how to operate.
We've got products there.
No, no, come on.
And I knew
how to make it happen,
because I've been in retail
for 17 years.
I am the one here
out of your choices --
You know, before we go on
with half an hour of this...
I'm just gonna put a little more
pressure on it all,
just 'cause I'm having fun.
I'm gonna reduce my equity --
In other words,
if you do pay me back in
the 18 months that I suggested,
I'll drop it down to 10%.
So I'm gonna be 20%
down to 10%.
I'm the lowest
of them all now.
I would like you
to tell me
whether or not you're going to
take my offer now.
Hmm.
You won't allow us
to step out in the hallway
for just a moment?
Just step out
for just a minute?
The problem is sometimes
when you walk out,
things change in here,
right?
O'Leary: Right.
Mm-hmm. True.
You never know.
They're choppy waters.
Would any of you
be willing to team up?
Yeah, I'll go in
with Kevin's deal.
I think there is a value
in having more sharks.
$150,000 for --
okay.
It's 20%, but if they
pay it back in 18 months,
it drops to 10%.
Greiner: drops to 10%.
Those are your options.
What are you going to do?
Robert,
Mr. Wonderful...
I think we've got a deal.
...I think we have a deal!
O'Leary: All right.
Whoo!
All right!
CUBAN: Congrats, guys.
Herjavec: That was awesome.
This actually is
the best financial deal for you.
It's a great product.
Thank you all so much.
Greiner: Good luck.
Thank you.
Yay!
Yay! Good job!
I'm so excited!
Oh!
PAUL:
We really wanted Robert.
We were so excited
when he loved the design.
It was fantastic.
And to get Mr. Wonderful
in there, as well,
helping us grow the business,
could not have asked for more.
I think we just stick with
this design.
Yeah.
I think every kid
should see this in the morning.
They're gonna have nightmares
every night about it.
Narrator: Last season,
Marc newburger and Jeffrey Simon
made a deal
with Lori Greiner for their
car-Safety product, drop stop.
Drop Stop
reduces driver distraction
by keeping your eyes
on the road, not in your gap.
The built-In slot
is designed
to fit easily around
the seat-Belt catch like so.
You won't even know it's there
till it stops the drop.
We can make a lot of money
together,
but we can also save
a lot of lives together.
Let's see how Marc and Jeffrey
are doing now.
Since appearing
on "Shark Tank,"
we have sold hundreds
of thousands of drop stops.
And that's not just sales
for us.
That is
lots of jobs created.
Simon: In the short five months
since we aired,
we have grossed
over $5 million in sales.
In the next 12 months,
we project
over $15 million in sales.
And Lori just landed us
our first National retail deal.
Greiner: [ gasps ]
Oh, my.
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my god!
[ laughing ]
Not only
did we get into walmart,
but we got
into 3,500 walmarts.
That was an order
valued at $2 million.
What a dream come True.
My God.
This is unbelievable.
Dream come True.
Amazing.
We're going to take over
the world,
and we're not gonna stop
until every seat gap is filled.
We are going to make
a ton of money together,
but we're also gonna help
save lives.
She's the best partner
we could have,
and we have
just gotten started.
Whoo!
A few months ago,
after appearing on "Shark Tank,"
We were honored to
get an e-Mail from an
OFFICER, David Gerlach,
and said drop Stop
could really help
to reduce driver distraction
for officers.
So that's why we came
out here -- We wanted to
donate a set of drop stops
to all 425 officers
of this police department.
Literally, to be able
to give something back
to the people who,
every single day, risk
their lives for us,
it's just truly
a dream come True.
All:
Don't drop and drive!
I'm Kelley coughlan.
And I'm jenn Deese.
And we are best friends
living in Sunny Santa Monica,
california.
We're typical l.A. Girls.
We love going Out and can't live
without our phones.
Melrose P.R.
This is Jen.
We launched our own company,
melrose P.R.
We represent clients in travel,
hospitality, entertainment.
Working in P.R. In l.A.,
we're at the forefront
of the industry.
There's lights,
there's cameras,
there's red carpet,
and it's always showtime.
Our product keeps all your
essentials at your fingertips,
so gone are the days of digging
through your oversized handbag.
We help lighten your load
and keep you stylin',
all at the same time.
We know we can get exposure
with our P.R. Backgrounds,
but we need help
with sales.
We don't know how to get
into big-Box retailers.
We want every woman to be able
to have our product,
but we need the help of
the sharks to make that happen.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Kelley coughlan.
And I'm jenn Deese.
And we are
the creators of...
pursecase.
Pursecase.
We are here seeking
a $55,000 investment
in exchange for 12%
in our company.
If you were to ask people
what's the one thing
that they would never
leave the house without,
we are confident that
a smartphone would top the list.
We love our clutches
and our totes, but in reality,
they're just not
the most convenient accessory
for busy publicists
like ourselves.
[ cellphone RINGS ]
[ laughter ]
How many times
have you heard that noise
and had to dig through
your oversized handbag
to find your phone?
And who wants to shove
their smartphone
in the back pocket
of their skinny jeans?
Not cute.
So, this leaves you
with one option, and that is
carrying your phone around
with you in your hand,
which you might
accidentally drop
or you're gonna eventually
Put down somewhere
and forget about it
and lose it.
We kept asking ourselves,
why isn't there
something that keeps
everything we need
easy to access
and secure?
There has to be a better way.
There has to be.
Well, now there is.
Introducing pursecase...
ta-Da!
...The first ever
smartphone clutch
that's elegantly designed
with just your phone
and your essentials in mind.
Now you can keep
your cash, cards, and I.D.
All at your fingertips
in the most stylish way.
Pursecase comes
in a variety of colors
to help accessorize
any outfit,
always
with a stylish chain handle,
which doubles
as a bracelet,
and a compact mirror
just in case
of a fashion emergency.
Deese: So, now I'm gonna
pass them out for you guys.
Here's the classy white
for you.
'cause I'm a classy guy.
Of course!
Your daughters
can fight over that.
The royal purple
for you, Lori,
queen of qvc.
Thank you. [ laughs ]
the black for you,
Mr. Wonderful.
I love it. Thank you.
Herjavec: Oh!
I accept the bribe.
Greiner: Oh, I got money.
[ laughs ]
I got money, too!
DEESE: And then blue
for the mavs for you, mark.
Yes, ma'am. Thank you.
Coughlan: Sharks, we know
we have a hit on our hands,
and we are
at the tipping point.
We are hustlers,
and we are ready
to start making your money back
immediately.
Deese: So, which lucky one
of you wants to ride this wave
to millions of dollars
with us?
Join the pursecase team,
and you, too,
can be stylin'...
and Dialin'.
Kelley, I just -- I just
came back from europe.
We were in Italy,
and you see cases
that look exactly like this
for phones, covers.
You do,
but not with a pocket.
That's the only difference.
Yeah.
So everything
you're showing me here,
including
the little handle,
is all over Europe
in those little, cheap stores,
except the pocket.
That's right.
Correct.
Greiner:
I have a question.
You guys know
phones are constantly changing.
Absolutely.
So what smartphones
do you have pursecases for?
Currently,
we're making pursecase
for iphone 4
and iphone 5.
However, we have filed for
a utility patent,
which covers the functionality
of having the flap
for a credit-Card, I.D.,
a little bit of cash,
and, also,
with a chain handle.
How much do you think
you'll sell of this stuff?
We're just now starting
to fulfill orders.
But in the first
three months,
we did $30,000
simply of preorders.
Wow.
And then we've projected
for this first calendar year
of ours, in business,
about $240,000.
What does it cost you
to make it?
$4.42.
And then it's $15 wholesale,
$38 retail.
Our margins
are really good --
88% when we sell
direct Online
and then 71%.
O'Leary: You don't find it
a little steep at $38
for the online orders?
We've had no resistance
to the price whatsoever.
Ladies, you should be
selling it for $19.95
and you'd sell
10 times more.
We did some P.R.
Around the initial prototypes,
and the demand
was just insane.
And a manufacturer
actually came to us.
Who is that?
Did they do a deal
with you?
It's called
dall international,
and it's
a logistics company.
And they said, "Listen,
"We want to make a deal
with you guys.
We see this as being
a huge opportunity
for our company."
What's your deal with them,
though?
15% equity stake
in the company.
But they have extended us
a million-Dollar credit line.
Wow.
Cuban: Good for you guys.
We can do any-- I mean, we can
get things here in 45 days.
So, why do you need
the $55,000?
We're looking to cast
a wider net.
We're gonna spend
some of the money on molds
to move into
the Samsung galaxy s4.
That's the initial
one that we have a
lot of demand for.
Do you know
I sell something
that looks really similar
to that already...
didn't know that.
Ooh.
...on Qvc?
What does it
look like?
It looks
very much like that.
Jenn, Kelley, I-I admire
all the work that you've done,
but seriously...
I just spent two weeks looking
at this on every street corner.
I'm out.
Well, we appreciate that.
Coughlan: Thank you.
We appreciate that.
Corcoran:
I think, jenn and Kelley --
I think the design on this
is adorable.
Thank you. Thank you.
It's very Chanel-Y.
And I'm sure that's
exactly what you're after.
I think the Mirror's clever.
But the two pieces
I would have liked to have seen
is a change purse
and basically no flap.
I kind of like it
streamlined.
Not for me. I'm out.
Okay.
We appreciate that.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you.
Guys, I'll go next.
Um...
I'm not a fan of the
technology-Accessory business.
That's just not me, because
it's just e-Everybody's whim,
and if you make a zig
and Everybody else zags,
you're out of luck.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
O'Leary:
I like you guys, and I think
what you brought to the table
is rather unique,
particularly
a million-Dollar credit line.
That's pretty rare.
So here's an offer for you.
I give you $55,000.
I get $1 a unit
until I get my $55,000 back,
and then I get 75 cents a unit
in perpetuity.
Herjavec: Wow.
Appreciate your offer.
Thank you for your offer.
Wasn't expecting that.
You know, I always say
I can tell instantly
if it's a hero or a zero.
And the minute
that you walked in here,
I looked at it,
and I thought...
...it's a superhero.
I really like it.
Now, it is very much like
something that I already sell.
But because I've sold
hundreds of thousands
of my own...
we know.
...I think that I can sell
hundreds of thousands
of these, too.
So I'm gonna make you
an offer.
And my offer is...
$55,000, 15%.
That's it.
That's a deal.
Lori, you've got a deal.
Like, no questions asked.
You've basically gave us
exactly what we wanted.
Oh, my.
And thank you.
But Kelley, jenn,
what about Kevin's offer?
Mr. Wonderful, we so
appreciate the offer, but...
we really do
appreciate that.
We came in here for Lori.
You know we did.
I love it. I love it.
Thank you!
I think it's awesome.
We're so excited!
Aah!
[ laughs ]
That's exactly
what we wanted,
and I cannot wait
to work with you.
Thank you! Aah!
It's really, really cute.
Thank you, everyone!
Thank you guys so much!
Nice job.
[ laughing ] Oh, my God.
I might cry.
Yes!
We're gonna sell a million!
Does it not worry you
that there's
so many things like it
out there?
Cuban: For $55,000?
No, because I have
the perfect medium.
I have a show on qvc.
Yeah. This is perfect
for qvc.
It's just a line extension
to you.
My customers
will love this,
and I want to bring it
to them at a great price.
Good job, Lori.
That'll be great for you.
Herjavec: Wow.
Narrator:
Next up is an entrepreneur
with a sweet take
on customization.
[ Boston Accent ]
Hello, sharks.
My name is Joe dauenhauer,
and my company is chocomize.
I'm seeking $500,000
in exchange for a 20% equity
interest in my company.
The current chocolate-Bar market
hasn't seen much innovation
in its products
in a very long time.
Quite frankly, most chocolate
bars are just plain Boring.
Chocomize solves this problem
by allowing customers
to create their own
chocolate bars online.
Let me show you how it works.
Customers start
by choosing a shape.
Then, they choose
a belgian-Based chocolate
of milk, dark, or white,
and the choice to add
up to five toppings
from a selection of over 100.
In addition to creating the
chocolate bar of your dreams,
our bars are perfect
for all occasions.
We put special edible messages
in the chocolate bars,
such as "Happy birthday."
We also can put
special edible corporate logos
or pictures
in the chocolate bar,
making it great for
corporate events and weddings.
So I've packed up some dreamy,
delicious chocolate bars
that have been made special
for each one of you.
Greiner:
You're from massachusetts?
Easy to tell, right?
I love your accent.
I love that accent.
Thank you.
Herjavec: Thank you.
Greiner: Thank you.
Low-Cal, right?
[ laughs ] Completely.
[ Laughs ] low-Cal.
Oh, it's cute.
Wow. This tastes great.
Corcoran: Mmm.
Joe, what's the middle
made from, the picture part?
Can you eat that, too?
Everything's edible.
What are you doing
in the chocolate business?
My partner, Fabian,
who's from Germany --
He started the company
three years ago.
And about a year and a half ago,
I decided to join him.
My background
is actually finance.
Greiner:
So, are you partners?
We're partners together.
Exactly.
What's the split?
He actually
owns half the company,
and myself and one
other shareholder own about 18%,
and then we have
two other shareholders.
So, Joe,
walk me through the numbers.
So, last year,
we -- We did $440,000 in sales.
Okay. But -- but what about
the year before? Just curious.
The year before,
we actually did $500,000.
Oh, so you had a dip
last year?
A small dip.
Part of the reason
is because we moved facilities.
We built out
a 5,000-Square-Foot facility
where we make
all the chocolate, so --
is this a really tiny niche
that's gonna stay tiny?
Because I guess
if I analyze your customers,
am I gonna find a bunch
of people buying it once,
having fun, giving it as
a gift, and that's about it,
or do I have repeat orders
from the same customers?
No, there's repeat orders.
We are by far the largest
customized chocolate in
the United States.
You got $500,000
in sales!
Yeah.
There's no company that's
dominant with $500,000 in sales.
But -- but -- but -- but --
but -- but this year,
we have
a very large car company
in the U.S. That we do
a promotional event.
In the last 12 months, we've
done over $125,000 in Sales.
Yeah, that's gonna be
your business --
Corporate-Type purchases,
as opposed to consumer.
Exactly, and that's what
we're trying to focus on.
Joe, walk me through the
profit margin on a single bar.
We sell our bars for
an average of $6 to $6.50,
depending on what toppings
and customization.
And what does it cost you
to make?
It costs us
about $2 to make.
Okay, but what's your plan
for your investors?
Let's say I actually
agreed with this valuation,
which I haven't even
started to tear the
peanuts out of yet.
Okay.
Let's just think
about the $500,000
I give you as a minority guy
with 20%.
How do I get
my chocolate back?
You're gonna
get your money back
in approximately
three to four years,
or in the case
of a liquidation event,
in which we're a great
acquisition target, our company.
Why would you -- Why
would you be a great
acquisition target?
'Cause I don't see it.
Be-Because -- Because the LARGE
companies mass-Produce.
What we do is -- Is --
is customize.
Do you know why they
mass-Produce?
Because they make money
that way.
Cuban: Where --
It's a much different model
than a mass-Production model,
which are not -- not alike.
I get that, right?
But there's nothing there
that can't be reproduced
by somebody else.
Could I take $2 million
or $2.5 million
and go and do
the exact same thing?
W-W-- I mean, you c--
You technically could do it,
but you'd be hiring people
to manage it --
people like me, who are
quality -- Quality managers.
All right. Today is
the best day of your life.
You've come
into the Shark Tank.
You've met me,
Mr. Wonderful.
I'll make you an offer.
Leave these guys.
[ laughs ]
I'll give you $500,000
to start from scratch.
You're my chocolate guy.
You're gonna get 25% equity
in the business.
That's a first.
[ chuckles ]
I wouldn't do that.
Why not? You're gonna get
a lot more equity.
And listen,
anybody can do it.
Anybody can't do it.
That's the problem.
We have a brand name.
We have customer loyalty.
People are beginning
to recognize who we are.
I don't have a brand name.
Nobody knows Mr. Wonderful.
I think I'll take a shot
at it now. You're starting
to get me interested.
Mr. Wonderful's chocolate --
Customized chocolate?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I'm in.
Dauenhauer:
I dare you to find a guy
that's as good as managing it
as me and Fabian.
I just found one.
It's you.
[ laughter ]
GREINER:
That's a first.
You know, Joe,
with all due respect to Kevin,
he thinks
he can run any business.
Of course.
O'Leary: And he can.
Hey, you know what,
there's no one better than Kevin
at running a business
into the ground.
[ laughter ]
herjavec: The -- the thing
that really turned me off --
what you've said to me is
I am the --
at half a million
a year,
I am the dominant guy
in the United States for this.
Well, the customized space
is small, right?
The customize-- It's --
It's a small market right now.
And that excites me?
Such a competitive
business. Ooh.
But -- but we don't know
how big it is
because we're -- We're -- We're
the first big -- Big player
in the market
in the United States.
Look, I love the chocolate,
but I'm not sharing
your -- your vision on the size
of the market.
Look, this is the thing.
It -- It's a tchotchke.
Look, I'm getting over
the sugar high.
I'm starting to crash.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Cuban: Look, if you came in
and said that you had
something very special in terms
of your s.E.O.,
in terms of your sales process,
you invented something --
but you haven't
done that at all.
You haven't
differentiated yourself.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Corcoran: You said, uh,
through your own admission
that customization
is expensive.
And from my way
of thinking,
that's what's wrong
with this business.
And when I look
at your packaging,
I really think
it looks dated,
not attractive,
and it wouldn't make me feel
like I'm giving
an EXPENSIVE or special anything
to someone.
That's part of what I want
to use the money for, is to
create new Packaging, as well.
I don't think you're
gonna generate a profit
on this business
for a very long time,
so I'm out.
Okay.
I like the name
chocomize.
Chocomize!
I think that's clever.
But this is
a very niche market.
For me, I like to go big,
and I like to invest
in things that are
gonna go really big.
And I don't see that
for this,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
As usual, all roads
lead back to Mr. Wonderful.
So let me reiterate
my offer, okay?
I'll give you $500,000
and 25% equity
in Mr. Wonderful's
customizable-Chocolate business.
Okay.
You come and work for me.
We use my Boston offices.
Okay.
And we start with
our first Mr. Wonderful bars
that have a slogan I love --
"You're dead to me."
We're gonna sell
millions of them.
Okay.
Yes or no?
Sorry. No.
All right.
Well, Joe, I'm gonna go online.
I'm gonna order my first
"you're dead to me" Bar,
and it's going to you.
[ laughter ]
I will -- I will
be ready for it.
Thank you.
You are dead to me.
I'm out.
Thank you very much, guys.
Thank you.
I feel pretty good
I think I held strong
and I stayed loyal
to my management team.
Mr. Wonderful -- I-I can't
wait till he starts his
own chocolate company.
And, you know,
we'll compete directly with him
and hopefully crush him, and
I can send him a bar that says,
"Hey, you should have
invested in Chocomize."
He's got a nice, little
business. You can't
crush him for that.
Yeah, it is.
It's a small, little business.
Why -- Why wouldn't I start
this myself if I want to be
in this business?
You could,
but why would you?
Well, I'd hire him.
Come on.
That's a first. He tried
to steal Someone's employee.
[ Boston Accent ]
Customized chocolate bar!
[ Laughter ]
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is a husband-And-Wife team
with a twist
to a common accessory.
Hi, sharks.
We're Rick and Melissa hinnant
from Austin, texas,
and we're here today to
knock your socks off, literally.
Our company is
grace & lace,
and we're seeking $175,000
for a 10% equity stake
in our company.
Grace & lace
has taken the Boring sock...
Boring!
...that women wear
under their boots,
and we've turned it into a Lacy,
frilly fashion statement.
Our story starts
a couple of years ago.
I had an idea
for a cute, little, Lacy sock
that stuck out
of my boots.
So after about nine hours
on the sewing machine
and a ton of frustration,
I finally made
my first pair.
Everywhere I wore them,
people would stop me
and ask me where I got them.
When I said I made them,
literally, strangers would
give me their phone number,
ask me to make them a pair.
So I threw up online
to see if they'd sell.
They did, instantly.
Before we knew it,
a business was born,
and we had
an accidental company.
And Melissa's gonna show you
some of our top Sellers.
Here. Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Really quite beautiful.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Cuban: Thank you.
Appreciate it.
O'Leary: What's your sales?
Corcoran: What are your sales?
Our first calendar year,
2012,
we did
over $800,000 in sales.
Whoa!
Wow!
$800,000?
Our last 12 months
to date,
we did $1.125 million
in sales.
Hey!
CORCORAN: You've got to be
kidding me.
I'm not kidding you.
Wow. That's very good.
I was going to ignore you
completely, but now...
Yeah.
Are you selling them all
online?
Um...
90% of our sales
are online.
Wow. Good for you.
And August of last year
was our first launch
into stores,
so we're now
in over 230 stores.
Melissa, you've sold
a million dollars. Unbelievable.
How do people
even know you're out there?
Social networking.
We have never paid a dollar
for any marketing.
Not one?
What -- what -- What -- social
marketing are you doing?
Facebook, twitter.
Okay,
so you're on facebook.
How many followers
do you have?
Um, almost 34,000.
What else are you using?
'cause 34,000 followers
isn't going to translate
into a million in sales.
Just blogs.
This picture right here
of my legs
was actually --
Pinterest 2012,
it was one of their
number-One pinned items.
Wow. That's a big deal.
Really?
Ah, there you go.
Wow.
What is that made out of?
It's cotton.
It's delicious.
Very --
It feels
almost like cashmere.
How much does this beautiful
set of socks sell for?
$34.
You're kidding.
What does it cost you
to make the same pair of socks?
That one right there
costs $5.
Amazing.
O'Leary:
I'm Loving you.
What -- What did you make in
2012 with $800,000 in Sales?
Yeah, your margins
must be incredible.
What was the profit?
Over $300,000.
I'm really happy for you,
and I think that it's great
that you've made
this incredible success.
I have to be honest, though.
It-- it did shock me.
It still shocks me.
I'm glad you did it, but I
can't relate to the product.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Herjavec: Look, the --
the proof is in the money.
Convince me why you need
$175,000 today.
[ sighs ] we need
a strategic partner.
Two weeks into my business,
after I sold my first pair,
we got an e-Mail
from Nordstrom's asking
if I had the ability
to make 30,000 to 50,000 pairs.
At that time, I didn't even know
that I could make 20.
That's ridic--
There's no way.
You obviously don't need
the money. What do you need?
Like I said, I think that
we can grow this company
to $5 million
to $10 million.
I think that we have
the capability to do that.
But we're looking
at you guys
to take us
to $100 million plus.
It could be
much bigger than that.
And that's
what we're looking for,
is the strategic part
more than anything.
Corcoran:
I'd like to put an offer
on the table, get it going,
'cause I think we have
a lot of interest here.
I think
your valuation is good.
I don't think you're greedy
based on what your sales are.
So I'm willing to give you
$87,500 for 5% of your business
if you get another shark
in with me.
Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
I'll give you $175,000
for 20%.
It drops down to 10% as soon
as you pay back the capital.
That assures me
my capital comes out.
And I'm willing to put more
back in if I have to.
Um...thank you
for your offer.
I will consider that.
Consider it. Yeah.
Who else is gonna step up?
I know you're thinking
Pretty hard over there, Robert.
You know, what you
need, I think, is you
really need guidance
to -- if you want
to get to that size.
I agree.
It's almost one of those
that seems too good to be True,
but I'm gonna take you
at your word on it.
I'll give you $175,000
for the 10%.
Would you be interested
in having Barbara in
on this deal with us?
I think she brings
a lot to the table.
He's giving you
exactly what you want.
Yeah, Rick. I-I don't --
I don't need Barbara
on the deal.
Rick: Okay.
And that's a fair question
they can ask.
But, Melissa, hang on.
You came in asking
for $175,000 for 10%.
I just offered you
exactly what you're asking for.
What are we going to do?
Can we hear from
the last shark
that's been staring a hole
through us...
[ Laughter ]
...real Quick?
Rick, hang on.
I don't think
it's fair to me
for you to say,
"Offer us
exactly what we're asking for,
but let me see
what the other guy has to say."
Of course he has
that right.
So for all due respect...
yes.
...I'd like an answer
to my offer.
And I absolutely want
to respect you.
I also want to hear
everything else.
And I think, you know,
being a smart businessman,
you would understand that,
as well.
Would you agree?
You -- You got to make
a decision on my deal.
I mean, I'm --
I'm happy to pull out...
sure.
...and let you deal
with the other guys,
or I'm happy to
have you take my deal.
I'm just --
I'm just interested in
hearing what is out there
so I can make the best educated
decision for you and me.
Rick, I gave you
exactly what you're asking for.
I understand.
What is there left to decide?
In the Shark Tank, we call this
bone-In-Mouth disease.
It's a dog looking
into a pond with a
bone in their mouth.
Kevin, I don't -- I don't need
you to make it better or worse.
But I'm just telling you
right now
it is bone-In-Mouth disease
right here.
For the 10% -- Kevin, quiet!
This is the dilemma
of the Shark Tank.
I'm Loving the drama.
I'm Loving it.
Quiet!
It's $175,000 for 10%.
It's what you asked for.
Can I ask you
a few more questions?
Yes or no?
Narrator:
One shark is out.
Barbara and Kevin
have offers on the table,
but Robert
has offered Rick and Melissa
exactly what they asked for --
$175,000 for 10%.
Yes or No?
Can I ask you
a few more questions?
I've given you
exactly what you're asking for.
I'm a very nice guy,
but don't mistake my kindness
for weakness.
Yes or no?
Greiner: You guys,
this is a moment
that you don't want to
walk away from and say, "uh-Oh."
$175,000 for 10%.
I-I'm happy to go out.
Can we discuss it outside?
You guys, you could
lose this offer.
Rick, I'm -- I'm --
I'm out.
O'Leary: Oh!
[ groans ]
you know why I like that?
Because your options
are lessened.
And I would actually do the deal
that I offered to you.
Cuban: Look, I like
what you guys are doing.
Question is, where are you gonna
need the most amount of help?
So when you
did your projections --
$1 million, $5 million,
$10 million, $100 million --
What were the pain points
where you said,
"Oh, my goodness, how am I
gonna get through this?"
that's what I want to know.
We're not looking to suck
a ton of your time,
because we understand
time is the only commodity
that we can't
get more of.
Amen.
So I'm looking to be able
to call and say,
"Hey, you know,
we're at the $5 million mark,
"and we are gonna expand
this year to $10 million.
What should we be doing?"
Okay, I'll offer you
$175,000 for 10%.
But I need to know right now
yes or No.
Can we talk about it
in the hallway?
Corcoran: Wow.
There's a difference
between trying to gather
as much information as you can
and indecision.
There are gonna be many
times in the evolution
of your business
where you can't be indecisive,
and right now
you're demonstrating
that you're
being indecisive.
Yeah, but we came in
with a strategy,
and we knew
who we wanted,
so it wasn't indecisive --
Not at all.
I'm going to revise
my offer.
I'm gonna change the offer
to give you exactly
what you asked for,
but half of the money
is going to be a line of credit.
Okay.
So what's the answer?
The answer is We would love
to do business with Barbara.
We think that she
brings the most.
O'Leary: Whoa.
You know what? You picked
the smartest person here.
Good decision.
I think it was
a very good decision.
Thank you.
Terrifically done.
You were great under pressure.
Thank you.
Terrific together.
We -- we came in with
a plan, and sometimes
it works out, right?
Herjavec: Nice job.
O'Leary: Congratulations.
Greiner: Good luck.
Rick: Thank you, guys.
Best of luck to you.
Melissa: Thank you, guys.
Greiner: Congratulations.
Good luck in retail.
Whew!
Can you believe it?
Holy cow!
We went with our gut,
and it worked out,
with the exact partner
that we wanted.
Yeah.
Absolutely incredible.
It couldn't have gone better.
We did it!
Melissa:
I think Barbara just has
the same kind of type
of thinking that we do,
and she just has
that go-Get-'em attitude,
and I think that we'll just pair
really well with her.
Mm-hmm.
They were
great negotiators.
Well, they just do
what they wanted.
They should have
just asked for Barbara
is what
they should have done.
That's all right.
You know what?
They were sharks wearing socks.
[ laughter ]
I don't know
if they were sharks.
Well said.